مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه
بلبيسي ناديه اهلا بك مساء الخير من عدنا
اهلا وسهلا بك مره جديده في مساء العربيه
كيف يبدو المشهد والوضع والاستعدادات قبل
بدء المحاكمه محاكمه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
مساء الخير سهام ونادين يوم تاريخي في
الولايات المتحده لرئيس مثير للجدل
والتغطيه اعلاميه غير مسبوقه يعني هناك
اكثر من الف صحفيه ينتظرون وصول الرئيس
دونالد ترامب الى محكمه الجنايات خلفي هنا
في منهاتن هناك وجود مكثف للشرطه يعني كل
نصف ساعه تقريبا نرى عدد اكبر من رجال
الشرطه والان قبل قليل كانت هناك مروحيه
ايضا تحلق في سماء المدينه طبعا نحن ننتظر
وصول الرئيس الذي سياتي مع محاميه سيدخل
الى قاعه المحكمه ستبدا الاجراءات تريد ان
نقود انه اليوم ليست محكمه الرئيس ترامب
اليوم هو بدء هذه الاجراءات وطبعا سيتم
اخذ بصمات الرئيس لن يقيد كما تم الاتفاق
مسبقا طبعا وقد يؤخذ له صوره ما تسمى
بالماك شوت او لا لا نعرف حتى الان واهم
شيء المحاكمه هي التهم نعرف بان هناك اكثر
من 30 تهمه وان المدعي العام طبعا والقاضي
سيقدمون هذه التهم امام الرئيس الذين توقع
ان يقول بانه غير مذنب وبعد ذلك سيترك
النيويورك ويتوجه الى طبعا مره الارجو في
ولايه فلوريدا وناديه بالتاكيد نحن نتابع
معك هذه المشاهد مباشره لانصار ومعارضي
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يحتشدون من امام محكمه الجنايات في منهات
حيث تقفين ناديه اليوم ناديه طالما انت
غطيتي طوال كل هذه السنوات وانت ضليعه جدا
في الشام الامريكي كيف سيتلقف الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دومين ترامب هذه
الاتهامات او لائحه الاتهامات هذه لكي
ربما يستفيد منها في انتخابات الرئاسه عام
20 24
الرئيس ترامنا دين هو سيد استغلال الفرص
ويحول كل الازمات الى فرص جديده والدليل
بانه استطاع ان يجمع خمسه مليون دولار في
24 ساعه عندما قال لمناصريه بان هذه
المحاكمه مسيسه وعلى فكره ثلثي الامريكيين
يتفقون معه وقالوا بالفعل بان السياسه
لعبت دور في هذه المحاكمه لكن المفارقه
ايضا بان ثلثي الامريكيين يريدون محاكمه
الرئيس ترامب لكنه طبعا الخطاب الاهم ربما
في حياه السياسيه هو الليله في مرالو في
منزله بين مؤيديه ومناصريه ومحبيه سيوجه
خطاب للامه سيتحدث فيه عن هذه
الاتهامات الباطله من وجهه نظره لكن كما
تعرفين هناك سلسله من التحقيقات وقد تكون
مفاجاه اليوم بالنسبه للاتهامات نحن نعرف
ان احد هذه التهم قد ترتقي لجنايه وقد
يدان الرئيس لكن ايضا هذا يعتمد على
القاضي الذي ه رغم انه يتهم
يوصف بالنزاهه قالت ترامب طبعا بانه لن
يتلقى محاكمه عادله لكن القاضي قد ينظر
الى التهم ويقول بانها غير كافيه لان يكون
هناك محاكمه يمكن ان يغلق هذا الملف اليوم
هذا غير متوقع لكن هو احد السنين المطروحه
طبعا
وهناك طبعا انصار للرئيس منهم
نواب متطرفين في الجو الى هنا لكن العدد
الذي رايته انا في اقتحام مبنى الكونجرس
في السادس
ومحبيه ومؤيديه ومناصريه الى ان ياتوا الى
نيويورك اولا هو ايضا لان مختلف هو لا
يريد ان يقلب نتائج الانتخابات كما حدث
سابقا وقال بان سرقت منه هو الان يواجه
اتهامات بانه دفع اموال لممثله اباحيه
المكان والظروف ويعني
الاتهام مختلف تماما لذا لا نتوقع احداث
عنف نتوقع ان تمر بسلام هذه المحاكمه
اليوم وهناك وجود مكثف ل 30 الف عنصر من
شرطه نيويورك لذا لا احد يتوقع ان يكون
هناك اعمال عنف شكرا جزيلا لك من نيويورك
مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه
بلبيسي شكرا ناديه